nach großbritannien sieht man anhand
steigender zahlen auch hier wieder das
virus wütet mehr als 760 menschen sind
bereits gestorben
unter den infizierten mit leichten
symptomen sind auch einige prominente
wie etwa prinz charles und heute nun kam
die nachricht nicht nur der britische
gesundheitsminister hat corona sondern
auch premierminister johnson selbst den
kampf gegen das virus will er jetzt von
zu hause aus führen gestern abend sah
man boris johnson noch mal draußen vor
der tür von number 10 downing street
weil sie mit dem finanzminister nahmen
teil am landesweiten beifall klatschen
für die angestellten des
gesundheitswesens nun kann der
premierminister aus erster hand
berichten wie das ist mit dem virus
erkrankt zu sein und übermorgen in seine
milde symptome das heißt eine erhöhte
temperatur und einen anhaltenden husten
daraufhin wurde mir geraten einen test
zu machen der war positiv ich arbeite
jetzt von zu hause bei den
regierungsgeschäften wurde zuletzt
verschärft abstand gehalten wie hier bei
der fragestunde im parlament
pressekonferenzen fanden nur noch per
videolink stadt doch das kam
möglicherweise zu spät auch der
gesundheitsminister ist inzwischen
positiv getestet worden und
außenminister dominik rapp der
gegebenenfalls für johnson einspringen
müsste wurde erst vorgestern noch in der
downing street gesehen gut für die
beiden verantwortlichen politiker dass
sie nur leichte symptome zeigen wer
jetzt in großbritannien am corona die
ruß schwer erkrankt sieht sich
erheblichen engpässen im über lange
jahre unterfinanzierten gesundheitswesen
konfrontiert die kurve der krankheits
und todesfälle schnellt in die höhe
gestern waren erstmals über 100 neue
todesfälle hinzugekommen heute waren es
weitere 181
vor allem in london rolle ein tsunami
auf die krankenhäuser zu warnen ärzte
die kritik dass strenge maßnahmen die
ausgangs beschränkungen zu spät
erfolgten wird immer lauter
für die kritiker der regierung entbehrt
es nicht einer gewissen ironie dass der
premier und der gesundheitsminister nun
selbst möglicherweise opfer dieser
zögerlichen haltung geworden sind